on va passer maintenant à une autre
forme de blague c'est le psy jury tu
perds c'est très simple on va faire
c'est top ça te plait chantal ne connais
pas mais je crois que c'était ce que tu
peux expliquer aux téléspectateurs
je dois être par exemple tiré de la
droite et ouais tu ali g la nuit aux
partenaires qui est devant moi il aura
de l'eau dans la mine armées de paris re
exactement si naulleau sinon mamar aux
braves
[Applaudissements]
attention combien battle gad je vais te
demander de venir ta soir tu vas juste
prendre de l'eau dans la bouche et
ensuite ce sera au tour de chantal pour
cette première battle lequel des deux va
rire d'abord sega n'est pas une petite
musique qui fait peur ici vas-y voilà
c'est moi qui la raconte mais ce qui
fait peur c'est au play et moi qu'il
arrête moi c'est toi et moi c'est moi je
fais quoi
bats toi tu dois pas rien
attention à tentation avec chantal ça va
être facile ce jeu mais je dois garder
l'eau dans la peau comme ça dit quoi
oui mais voilà va regarder là mais il
boit gad elmaleh
j'aime beaucoup ce que du fait que des
pays occupe quand il pète devant tout le
monde
désolé geppetto pas prévu ça et seule
chose est très loin de ce que doit quant
à elle parce que je m'attendais pas à ça
tu à paris tout à paris non non parce
que jean-jacques pas marc gental
non mais c'est fou ce truc
kyoshin qu'à piocher une carte faut
espérer avoir une mauvaise vanne en face
et ça non bref c est ce que si tu les
laisses que si tu me racontes mal ça
veut dire que tu les comprend pas non
pas forcément
chantal on dirait jean pierre foucault
qu'est ce qu'un chameau à trois boss ne
répond pas assez amusant c'est un
chameau qui s'est cognée sont abattues
rétention qui me dit tu sais mon cher
face à gan tu peux prendre à d'autres je
tenais je tenais à nos terres j'te
madère prend vas-y qui dit la blague toi
tu vas dire l'abri moi j'ai dit là bas
les tue à dire sans beaucoup geppetto
elle était super produit non mais t'as
bu l'eau mais non non alors qu'est ce
qu'un qu'est ce qu'un oiseau qui se
grattent que d'un côté je me dis un
oiseau migrateur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu reste libre est ainsi situé qualité
assez cool de gagner ma merde
attention philippe labelle alors qui
fera c'est toujours toi c'est toujours
moi toujours là bas et et okc ce n'était
pas présent mauvaise vanne prend une
mauvaise d'un débat du jus d'orange
j'ai rien dit alors quel super héros
donne le plus vite leur c'est spider man
c'est bon c'est bon
y a pas dit si tu bois à toi philippe tu
peux prendre une blague pourrie mais
c'est ça le but on fait je crois que 10
1 oignon quand on apprend que di antonio
quoi qu'en dise que yannick djalo diop
discute
aïe ça passe sur toi à toi ça te reste
bien sûr n'est pas à moi de vous
protéger
alors quel est le quel est leur pape
préféré de dracula
le croque le croque-monsieur des parties
signifie qui est tenant du titre
non mais enfin je vais maintenant dans
la bouche c'est déjà un peu galerie mais
c'est ça le truc déjà même la question
de la peau mais je savais pas et pose la
question comme foucault onuci presse a
vraiment fait une faciale non là ça va
être très dur de faire
[Musique]
voilà six mois
bonjour c'est toi c'est toi celui qui
raconte c'est lui le tenant du titre
allait charger une bonne bouche [ __ ]
un pas alors attention
qu'est ce qui n'est pas un steak une
pastèque
[Rires]
il a tenu à toi aussi
en fait tu peux recoins et quel est le
comble pour un plombier que ses clients
prennent la fuite
ça passe ça passe un défi j'ai de la
chance n'est pas la plus d'enfants c'est
de la joute alors bonjour plus en
prenant plus de temps plaisir à ckoi un
pépito le soir on avait trop d'où je
suis poli l'a pas fait ce que je disais
ce jeu c'est nul parce que je veux
gagner tu te prends de la fleur il avait
fui parce qu'on faisait japon faisait
joue cool ou six prix turgot tu arrives
tu vas lozère j'en prends là car après
alors que fait une fraise sur un cheval
de fer à cheval s'est perdu dans ses
chars pour le faire rires non c'est bien
qu'ils commencent par fais quoi moi je
bois
oui tu as tu racontes tu raconte celui
qui boit vasic c'est lui qui arrive on
voit bien oui il aime bien à houla ah
oui
qu est ce qu un canif qu est ce qu un
canif un petit fiant un petit chien un
petit chien en position d'avant c'est
unique les vannes je suis désolé de dire
quoi actif maintenant finir à dix à dix
mois c'est ça oui tu peux raconter une
astuce vous à cannes est un film où se
cachent mozart dans le frigo parce que
mozart l heure
[Rires]
alors non non tu veux que tu vaux qui
donne au celi si tu veux garde yves
ugalde attend sa chance à ce jeu qui
naissent ils participent à ces autres
c'est un moment magique là tu vois que
disent les maîtres nageurs au nouvel an
à qui bon apnée notre métier y aura un
commentateur de danse et je passerai pas
duel qui participe pour la troisième
année le championnat international il
arrive en demi finale à las vegas
docteur vous pensez que je suis
nymphomane dès que vous me lâcher la
beach vous répond laurent baffie qui
retrouve ici un style bien à lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est gasquet bois le rendent à ramener
ta propre bouteille je le remplis à
delme allait on assiste là un match au
sommet les deux ont fait leurs preuves à
différents endroits
laurent baffie g thierry ardisson
pendant ces années maintenant chez cyril
hanouna et gad elmaleh jean azar alé lô
que fait une mouette qui partagent un
gâteau elle fait moins à toi bah oui les
six personnes qui disent ah ben non
alors baissé c'est vachement oppressant
que font deux brosses à dents mais non
mais non mais non mais non c'est trop
bête
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils respectent
pas les règles ma fille il ya la
distance de sécurité est bien que font
deux brosses à dents le 14 juillet est
une stress parce que c'est pas clair ce
qu'il veut en fait il a une grande force
de maîtrise que font deux brosses à
dents le 14 juillet et une autre tête un
feu dentifrice éléphants faire ma fille
tu penses que tu peux te fait rire
gagnent déjà la fin parce que toi je
veux que tu perdes oit est-ce que tu ne
ris pas tu penses que tu peux faire ma
fille chérie pas de la tente
gad me fait énormément rire ah ouais ben
pas là bas ça se voit je suis très fan
de gueule je sais oui
vas-y vas-y à toi bon bien les joueurs
beat couilles qu demi [ __ ] enculage
[ __ ] à tort be cool q ce demi [ __ ]
[ __ ] à tort vide couilles q ce demi
[ __ ] anti-atome ardisson ardisson a
dit son indice aux young boys
couillard 10h les couilles argy son
deuxième but we know it services a conçu
les [ __ ] à tort beach boys qt creator
bits
[Applaudissements]